president biden hitting the road pushing
his multi-trillion dollar spending plans
as he becomes increasingly unpopular
with the american people
this is a tax cut
it changes the lives
of the american people so let's get this
done
let's move
folks
we have the most we have the most
talented workforce in the world
what are we doing
what in god's name are we doing and by
the way you hear these numbers 3.5
trillion or 1.75 trillion
we pay for it all
it doesn't increase the deficit one
single cent
and with the backdrop of americans
facing product shortages and soaring
inflation bidet's approval numbers are
going off a cliff he is losing more
ground from the start of his term to now
than any other president since world war
ii treasury secretary janet yellen
warning that the high prices rattling
consumers well they are here to stay
when do you expect the inflation to get
back to the you know two percent range
which is considered normal 2022 2023
when
well i expect that to happen next year
we are going through a period of
inflation that's higher than americans
have seen in a long time but we haven't
lost control
and some of the media are telling
americans to just stop complaining the
atlantic writing worried about the
supply chain stop buying
so much stuff which is not really the
most american of attitudes jesse
no it is not um and
you know we get these types of things
when democrats are in office you know
it's all of a sudden it's our problems
the president problems become our
problems so the media can shift the
accountability to the american people so
you know shut up uh you pampered
shopaholic and start lowering your
expectations that happened a little bit
during the last democratic president
under barack obama we would get hit with
a domestic terror attack and we were
told that's your fault you islamophobe
or we'd get high gas prices and they'd
say oh you shouldn't have bought that
gas-guzzling suv and then a republican
gets into office and everything's his
fault racism sexism your
girlfriend's uh has a drinking problem
everything on the earth is that
president's problem but the problem with
joe biden is he's creating problems and
then he's ignoring the problems he's
creating the american people want him to
focus on the border and inflation he's
not doing either one and that's why his
poll numbers are sliding so dramatically
he's like either the tinder date you see
his picture he looks like a ten and then
you meet him at dinner and he's at two
it happens all the time right and you
have to sit down now through a four
course meal with this stiff and you're
thinking how do i get out of here you
know he was kind of had a blurry picture
during the election because he was
hiding biden and now he's in full focus
and he's ugly and we don't like this guy
so now you're seeing yellen come out
there can she go on paternity like mayor
pete did because every time she opens
her mouth i'm scared she comes out and
she misses inflation last year she poo
pooed it that's a verb and now we're hit
with a major inflationary appearance she
goes it's going to last until at least
next year and then she says this but we
haven't lost control wasn't that
reassuring from the treasury secretary i
feel so much better now that you guys
haven't lost control but now you have
high prices you have high fuel prices
and you have low growth and a weak
dollar and that is a recipe for disaster
so digging can we get your take on all
of that
i thought it was weird that janet yellen
was staring up at the ceiling like this
i don't know what she was looking at but
again when somebody won't look you in
the eye they're lying to you
it's not under control they have no the
federal reserve this is an unprecedented
experiment monetary policy of the amount
of money they've been pumping into the
system and they're ju they haven't even
begun to start pulling back on it
they're monetizing that they're buying
the debt that the federal government
issues that's alone is going to be a
disaster but i do love that if your
spending is going to be socialist then
the way you pay for it also needs to be
socialist and they're talking about this
new annual tax on unrealized capital
gains which is a wealth tax which is
i don't care what anybody says you're
confiscating people's wealth and it is
fraught with peril raises so many
problems whether it's only for
billionaires
my big fat backside it's only for
billionaires because what ends up
happening is these taxes this type of
tax never raises enough money the
billionaires are going to move so who
does it end up hitting uh people much
lower on the
financial scale look at the alternative
minimum tax originally designed to hit
less than 200 people hit millions and
millions of people a few decades from
there but it also will expand the power
of the internal revenue service
it's un-american and unconstitutional so
but again biden is governing for
applause and accolades overseas which is
where he's going later in the week and
that's why he's getting the double
middle finger from americans who drive
and shop at grocery stores his biggest
drop greg has been with some democrats
but mostly it was independence like just
free fall yeah and this is uh i think a
lot of it has to do with the fact that
he just keeps yelling at us why are you
telling me yeah why are you it's like
we're all pulling wheelies on his front
yard
on a sunday and he's coming out shaking
the rake to your you know your point
about we haven't lost control that is
part of the whole idea of setting a low
bar hey we haven't you know but this is
the this is the depends presidency they
have lost control um but the slogan is
suck it up uh and it's being pushed by
the media as you saw with that article
the same media that vows any
restrictions
um
medical care access or housing by an
illegal alien that would be seen as
bigoted but if you're an american you
suck it up you have to deal with loss
right you have to with diminished
availability of products so people who
aren't from america or illegal aliens
they get the carrot but it's the
citizens who get the stick and what's
hilarious is they're damning citizens
for buying stuff after they gave them
the money
to buy this stuff
so you're telling us that now we must
appeal to every irrational punitive
pronouncement that you have first take
the money now don't spend that money and
here's what also don't save it don't
save it either because that's bad but
it's here's my deal if you want
americans to pull back you have you have
to as well no more flights to push
climate change no more met galas no more
expensive dining out at insanely priced
italian restaurants you know this let
them eat cake thing is wearing thin
especially when we can't find
so president biden's going to new jersey
to campaign for uh democrat phil
murphy's running for re-election for
governor in new jersey confess i i've
been paying a lot of attention to
virginia not to new jersey i didn't
realize and now i've been educated today
by friends saying that this race is a
lot closer it quietly tightened do you
think there's a possibility that the
republicans could win
in new jersey probably not i mean it's a
blue state but you gotta remember we
talked a little bit about it before come
on i think this is this will be the
first time a democrat when phil murphy
wins gets gets re-elected as governor of
new jersey
i think in like 45 worried enough to
send biden in i don't know so i think
there's so then you add to it
all of the consternation around some of
the issues that we've raised here some
of the issues that we raised every other
day around most days about uh biden in
the immigration crisis and how this
might be bleeding over to these
candidates but i would remind everybody
as much as we sound a little gloomy
about things the down scp s p which is
not the only barometer closed at a
record today how trumping of you
know
my capitalists always have been and i
think that the democrat my democrats and
democrats i align with believe that now
are we where we want to be no there's no
doubt their prices prices have gotten
too hot but i would remind everyone also
we have incentivized investing in this
country to invest in companies and to
force management teams of companies to
be really efficient and as a result that
efficiency breeds a lot of things
including profitability including more
investors but sometimes when if demand
gets a little lopsided one way it
creates problems they didn't get all of
this right with uh with with all of the
stimulus and so forth i'd much rather
earn this out of giving people too much
during a crisis than during the moment
we we face than not further dagan said
it well as well since 2007 we've had
nothing but an experiment with the
federal reserve board and some of
they've got right some of they've gotten
wrong i actually wish they had heard a
little more sometimes maybe pulling back
and i think that's what summers was
saying a little while ago he didn't i
don't know if he was saying don't spend
as much on the stimulus although he did
say a little of that he was really
concerned about the fed so we've got to
look at all this on the table and in
fact when the fed
does what it does the people who win the
most are rich people do you have
confidence that the biden administration
is paying attention to those issues
there's smart people there and i think
janet yellen i don't know what she was
looking at when she was talking i didn't
see an interview but she's smart uh and
she's capable and clearly jerry powell
and the team they have the tools to do
what needs to be done if this thing does
get out of control but to your point
politically i think the country is
blaming democrats for this that's why
the president was in new jersey that's
why he's probably going to have to go go
to virginia but i'll tell you this
there's one guy on the democratic side
wouldn't count out ever in an election
that's terry mcauliffe he's the best
retail politician we have in our party
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else